[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'hebdo
pendant 26 minutes nous allons revenir
ensemble sur l'actualité qui a marqué
notre territoire cette semaine tout de
suite le sommaire mobilité autonome
territoire et citoyen c'était le thème
jeudi à 50 ans on y vit d'une conférence
sur le développement des réseaux
autonomes
plusieurs tables rondes ont permis de
mieux comprendre les enjeux alors des
grandes vacances a sonné vous allez être
nombreux à prendre le volant ce week-end
notamment en ile-de-france une période
kirin malheureusement trop souvent avec
accident jean yves petit directeur
départemental de la prévention routière
dans les yvelines sera avec moi en
bateau enfin nous reviendrons bien sûr
sur les résultats du baccalauréat 2019
mais aussi sur ses deux visites
ministérielles
cette semaine la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet la ministre des armées
florence parly était dans les yvelines
un moment de stress de cris de joie ou
encore de larmes jour j pour les 71
mille bacheliers yvelinois est depuis ce
matin ils découvrent leurs résultats
c'était le cas notamment au lycée
dumont-d'urville à maurepas pour les
sections es et s tmg premières réactions
recueillies par nicolas landry
je suis très contente parce que je
pensais vraiment passer au rattrapage et
du coup bah je les ai eus à 10,22 ne
sais pas comment j'ai eu mon bac
honnêtement en match 5 parce qu'il était
tellement dur le sujet mais j'ai réussi
à rattraper franchement je suis fier de
moi mais c'était beaucoup trop dur
vraiment et je suis trop trop contente
je suis libéré là mais je pensais que
j'étais sûr de l'avoir mais mention bien
c'est inespéré de jeu archi 14e les
juges pendant
ça a été dur un peu oui les maths j'ai
pas trop ri si les décors sont bien
déroulées mais voilà on a su garder
notre calme
on est tous ensemble on l'a tous eu
ensemble
donc tu sais quoi le programme donc là
le programme c'est la fête et encore
félicitations à eux alors on ne connaît
pas bien sûr encore le taux de réussite
pour cette session en 2019 et puisqu'il
faut attendre les résultats du
rattrapage la semaine prochaine on reste
dans le secteur de l'éducation on appris
que le directeur académique des yvelines
serge clément avait démissionné le
vendredi 28 juin information confirmée
par le rectorat et selon nos confrères
de 7,8 actuel serge clément serait mise
en cause dans une affaire de harcèlement
une enquête administrative a été ouverte
il occupait ce poste depuis le 12
décembre 2014
les grandes vacances débutent
officiellement ce soir vous allez être
nombreux à prendre l'avion le train et
puis bien sûr la voiture j'enlève petit
bonjour bonjour
elle vous êtes directeur départemental
de la prévention routière dans les
yvelines alors avant de parler des
départs en vacances
un mot sur le bilan des accidents dans
notre département puisque cette année de
janvier à mai la mortalité a baissé
on déplore dix tués sur les routes
yvelinoise contre 24 en 2018 pour la
même période
j'imagine que c'est une bonne nouvelle
en plus soit vous avez vous les tout
derniers chiffres avec vous oui j'ai je
peux ajouter je peux ajouter les
chiffres du mois de juin
c'est donc la fin du au 1er juillet 16
tués par rapport à 27 l'année dernière
donc effectivement c'est une bonne
nouvelle
alors vous expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles il y en a 19 ans de moins que
l'année dernière
c'est un peu délicat parce que ça reste
quand même des des petits des petits
chiffres donc il est assez difficile
d'en tirer des conclusions mais mais
c'est en tout cas une bonne nouvelle
et si l'année continue comme ça faut pas
faut pas vendre la peau de l'ours avant
de l'avoir tué mais ça sera peut-être la
meilleure année depuis depuis dix ans a
été abaissée à 80 km/heure sur certaines
routes
est ce que ça peut être dû
ça justement ce chiffre se vend ces bons
chiffres la vitesse est le principal
avec l'alcool le principal facteur
d'accidents sur nos routes
donc oui en réduisant la vitesse ça
contribue bien sûr aussi à la baisse de
la mortalité sur les routes mais ce
n'est pas la seule c'est pas la seule
donnée évidemment jeu il faut la voir en
détail les causes des accidents dans les
yvelines
la vitesse y est pour un certain nombre
d'accidents mais c'est très souvent
aussi de toute façon des vitesses
inadaptées à la circulation mais pas
forcément en excès de vitesse alors
l'heure des départs en vacances a sonné
ça y est beaucoup de bouchons sont
attendus notamment en île de france par
exemple péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines attend le
passage de 120 mille véhicules par jour
juste pour ce week-end en trafic dense
qui implique j'imagine beaucoup beaucoup
d'accidents et ben ça implique des
risques supplémentaires évidemment oui
ça va faire du monde à ça va faire du
vent la c1 tarn où le principal
alors il ya évidemment plein de conseils
à donner mais les cds ce sont les
conseils qu'on entend toujours sur
l'alcool sur le téléphone sur la vitesse
bien évidemment puisqu'on va avoir une
énorme densité de circulation sur
l'autoroute les comportements justement
adopté alors l'an iv bouchon mois la
principale chose que je veux dire au
delà de tous les conseils téléphone etc
c'est restons calmes restons calmes
c'est les vacances tout va bien même
s'il ya du monde sur la route
restons calme ça sert à rien de
s'énerver va forcément y avoir des gens
qui vont faire des zigzags entre les
files de voitures des voitures ou des
motos qui vont faire ça des gens qui
vont s'insérer pour pour serrer le
maximum qu on ait du mal à respecter les
distances de sécurité
d'autres qui vont mettre la musique à
fond bon ça sert à rien de s'énerver
restons calmes c'est vraiment ça le
principal la fatigue aussi des bouchons
qui peuvent entraîner une fatigue
alors j'imagine le port said
un bien dormi en fait donc évidemment
partons si possible reposer bien sûr et
puis avant de partir surtout pour les
voitures les plus anciennes faisons le
tour de la voiture les niveaux le
gonflage des pneus tout ça dans les
voitures modernes c'est devenu fayel il
ya des alarmes et les gens qui prennent
leur leurs caravanes ou leur camping car
une fois par an là aussi qu'ils fassent
le tour sérieusement en particulier les
pneus ce qui lui est quand même pas rare
de voir le long de nos autoroutes des
caravanes arrêté avec un pneu crevé donc
il vaut mieux regarder ça avant et le
chargement de la voiture mais dire c'est
normal c'est des vacances
le chargement de voitures évidemment
très important surtout vous le savez
bien en cas de freinage brusque voire de
tholot évidemment tout ce qui n'est pas
bien installé dans la voiture
ça va ça va promener dans tous les sens
donc les les bagages et les objets
lourds dans le fond de la voiture le
plus sur l'avant possible pour qu'en cas
de freinage brusque et bien la course de
ces objets soit la moins longue possible
il ya le client les coffres sur sur le
toit c'est ce qu'il ya une
réglementation justement base de toute
façon alors une réglementation oui il y
en a une je vous je le connais pas mais
enfin il est évident qu'il y en a une
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'il faut que le centre de gravité du
véhicule soit le plus bas possible pour
éviter pendant une bonne stabilité et
pour éviter les tonneaux dont pas voir
le centre gravité le plus bas possible
il faut mettre les objets lourds le plus
bas possible et donc d'enlever dans les
coffres de toit
si possible pas des objets trop lourd
donc on récapitule ont fait le tour de
sa voiture et puis on ne boit pas
d'alcool et on dort bien avant de
prendre le volant et on dort bien et on
reste calme et on reste calme même si
les autres vous énerve
juste un mot sur la prévention routière
est ce qu'elle sera présente sur les
aires d'autoroute non non en tout cas
dans les yvelines
moi je ne parle que les yvelines nous
sommes pas plus de 10 dans les yvelines
et moi je suis comme tout le monde je
prends les vacances alors vous restez en
plateau avec nos jean yves petit parce
qu'on va parler de véhicules là cette
fois ci de véhicules autonomes puisque
jeudi à saint quentin en yvelines une
série de tables rondes étaient
organisées pour parler notamment à des
enjeux liés à leur développement sur
notre territoire
des tables rondes pour mieux comprendre
l'enjeu des véhicules autonomes à
l'horizon 2035 ce marché devrait
représenter une manne financière de 900
milliards d'euros par an malgré ce
chiffre plusieurs paramètres freinent
son développement en france on a
énormément de start up en amande
entreprises qui sont à la pointe là
dessus mais malheureusement on n'arrive
pas à passer à l'échelle industrielle
le deuxième c'est le frein cognitif on
remarque aujourd'hui en france en fait
que la plupart des conducteurs et la
plupart des usagers sont pas encore
prêts en fait embrasser cette
technologie pourquoi parce qu'en fait
tout simplement on a peur parce qu'on ne
la connais pas le troisième c'est le
frein politique
vu que le véhicule autonome comme tout
autre véhicule présente un risque même
si je rappelle que la 90 qu'on estime
qu'à 90% des accidents sur la de la
route qui peuvent être évités grâce à la
technologie là
cette conférence était organisée au sein
du campus des services de l'automobile
et de la mobilité à guyancourt
plusieurs thématiques ont été abordées
comme l'impact sur l'emploi
à ce jour à 20000 emplois dédiés jus
dans ce secteur d'activités saint
quentin en yvelines et on désire qu'une
chose c'est qu'évidemment il y ait des
véhicules autonomes sur le territoire et
ses tables rondes elles ont pour
vocation aussi à des silos t entre les
opérateurs
les constructeurs les collectivités les
instituts de recherche donc donc je
pense que la suite majeur c'est de
contribuer à favoriser un écosystème en
mouvement vers des nouveaux services de
mobilité innovants et utiles
il y a deux mois le gouvernement
français présenté un plan pour le
développement des véhicules autonomes
d'ici à 2022 16 nouvelles
expérimentations sont prévues un peu
partout en france
mais jean-yves petit que pensez vous du
développement de ces voitures automnale
a alors moi je vais parler de ce qui me
concerne c'est à dire la sécurité
routière je veux pas parler de l'emploi
et tout ça mais oui c'est très
prometteur
c'est très prometteur le
là il ya un intervenant qui a dit que
90% des accidents pourraient être évités
grâce à ces technologies
en fait c'est que 90% des accidents qui
surviennent sur la route sont dus un
comportement humain donc évidemment si
une voiture autonome le comportement
humain passe au largement au second plan
et on peut estimer qu'on évitera tout
les problèmes de fatigue d'alcool de
téléphone au volant dont on parlait
maintenant il me semble qu'il a oublié
un élément un quatrième élément un frein
c'est le frein j'allais dire législatif
et réglementaire
comment va évoluer le code de la route
le code des assurances
et c'est là à mon avis on n'y est pas
encore c'est damien mais pas pour tout
de même à venir mais pas pour tout de
suite mais on met on fait des progrès
considérables quand même depuis déjà un
certain nombre d'années petit à petit on
y vient et les progrès sont déjà énorme
mais ça va continuer merci jean yves
petit en tout cas d'avoir accepté cette
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur départemental de la prévention
routière dans les yvelines est tout de
suite on passe à l'essentiel de
l'actualité
[Musique]
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet
était en visite mardi dans les yvelines
plus précisément à la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy accompagné de la secrétaire
d'état
christelle jboss elle a dévoilé les
grandes lignes de sa feuille de route
pour améliorer la santé des détenus
ce document contient les 28 mesures
mises en place par le gouvernement pour
améliorer la santé des détenus dans
cette maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy les
personnes incarcérées ont accès à une
unité hospitalière ou encore un centre
de lutte contre les addictions
on rencontre beaucoup de gens pour qui
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas beaucoup
de contacts avec le monde de la santé à
l'extérieur on a une population assez
jeunes sur bois d'arcy également et puis
on a des patients qui sont qui sont très
vulnérables qui ont sont dans des
situations sociales compliqué à
l'extérieur et qui ont mauvaise accès
aux soins scie à bois d'arcy les
structures médicales sont adaptés pour
prendre en charge les détenus ce n'est
pas le cas partout
d'où cette feuille de route qui s'étend
jusqu'en 2020 2 qui a plusieurs
objectifs
c'est permettre d'avoir un bilan je
pense notamment aux jeunes qui sont sous
protection judiciaire lié à la jeunesse
avec une facilité un bilan de santé
dès qu'ils sont en détention c'est aussi
de la prévention par rapport au suicide
la formation auprès des professionnels
pénitentiaire mais aussi professionnels
de santé prévenir aussi en termes de
dépendance est liée au handicap
favorisons la détection des personnes
détenues qui ont ces difficultés là
autre mesure annoncée le développement
de la télémédecine ou encore la mise en
place de stages en milieu pénitentiaire
pour les internes en médecine la
réinsertion des détenus est également
concernée c'est aussi notre volonté de
travailler sur la continuité du parcours
de soin après la sortie de la détention
c'est un défi majeur tout notre enjeu
c'est de faire le lien entre ce qui se
passe dans la détention et en dehors de
la détention
je crois que c'est un enjeu capital pour
éviter la récidive
il est également prévu d étude nationale
sur la santé mentale des personnes
détenues le dernier état des lieux date
d'il ya 15 ans le département des
yvelines a également reçu cette semaine
la visite de la ministre des armées flou
ans par lit elle c'était jeudi sur le
site de satory elle a réceptionné le
premier griffon qui à terme va remplacer
les véhicules de l'avant blindé de
l'armée de terre michael almy d'euros
étaient sur place
le blindé de demain officiellement
présenté à versailles la ministre des
armées florence pas réalité ce mercredi
4 juillet sur le plateau de satory pour
réceptionner les six premiers griffon à
véhicules clé du programme scorpion qui
renouvelle la game de l'armée de terre
le véhicule griffon qui est un véhicule
qui a vocation à remplacer les v abe les
véhicules de l'avant blindés qui ont
rendu de très bons et loyaux services à
nos armées qui ont maintenant près de 40
ans et qui sont prêts si je puis dire de
la retraite
le véhicule multirôle servira notamment
transporter des troupes l'engin a été
conçu en partie dans l'entreprise nexter
sur le plateau de satory un site qui
robots plus de 1000 collaborateurs
ici à versailles nous avons la direction
générale de la société le bureau
d'études qui travaille depuis des années
sur la conception de ces véhicules ainsi
que les services achats soutien et
différents services de la direction
générale donc c'est véritablement la
tête de nexter qui est ici même si les
usines se trouvent dans différents
départements français au total près de
1900 véhicule de type griffon seront
livrés d'ici 2030 le blindé sera utilisé
dans un premier temps dans la formation
des militaires il sera déployé sur le
terrain partir de 2021 respecter les
enjeux environnementaux pour la
construction proposée à un habitat qui
répondent aux besoins à voici l'objectif
de la charte de la promotion immobilière
résidentielle a été signé hier à la
salle du conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines entre
l'agglomération les promoteurs et les
villes plusieurs années de travail pour
aboutir à cette charte qui garantit
trois axes majeurs la qualité du
logement celle du cadre de
et la fluidité des relations entre les
différents acteurs de l'immobilier les
promoteurs respectant leur engagement se
verront remettre le label qualitri sky
par l'agglomération ont souhaité réguler
un petit peu cette construction cette
façon de construire en instaurant un
vrai dialogue entre les communes et les
promoteurs alors non pas qu'ils en
avaient pas du tout mais on s'est dit ce
serait bien de travailler ensemble faire
des arts on a fait des ateliers où on a
échangé les promoteurs ont pu nous
donner leurs propres contraintes et
leurs propres attentes
et puis de côté toutes les communes qui
ont participé ont aussi donné leurs
attentes et leurs contraintes
la charte a l'avantagé de regrouper
l'ensemble des des points qui sont des
points sur lesquels notre société très
très vigilante donc une qualité de
l'habitat une qualité de prestation
un confort de vie
là le développement durable qui soit le
plus développé possible et tout ça en
partenariat avec avec les collectivités
ce que j'ai trouvé très positif dans
cette charte qui m'a été présenté c'est
son côté non pas obligataires mais
incitateur et je pense que quand on a un
site et qu'on amène les gens ça génère
forcément une création de valeur et
surtout une dynamique d'essayer d'aller
plus loin ou autrement
des propos recueillis par patrick et
jacques de dixmude
comme chaque semaine nous vous ouvrons
les archives de tv 60,18 le 3 décembre
2012 était inauguré la fac de santé à
montigny le bretonneux
une inauguration en présence de simone
veil
[Musique]
ses apparitions se font de plus en plus
rares mais simone veil ancien ministre
de la santé celle qui a défendu et
obtenu le droit à l'avortement a tenu à
être présente pour l'inauguration de
l'ufr des sciences de la santé de
montigny qui porte dorénavant son nom
une ufr des sciences de la santé
autrement dit une université où l'on
enseigne à la fois le médical et le
paramédical première particularité la
seconde cette ufr est implantée dans la
ville et non au sein d'un établissement
hospitalier universitaire comme cela se
voit couramment et ce n'est pas un
hasard
on pense que ça ça permet pour partie de
réseaux des deux traités
les difficultés que l'on a à former des
professions de santé
on pense peut-être faire soit des
maisons de santé universitaire soit des
dépôts le sont et ils ont été des
endroits de soins de premier recours et
qui permettrait peut-être de désengorger
un petit peu les urgences des hôpitaux
et puis de prendre en charge de façon
très universitaire je dirais des malades
si tous les étudiants sont formés en
centre ville
si tous les étudiants passent l'ensemble
de leur cursus universitaire à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital
il y a peu de chances pour qu'ils aient
envie d'aller s'installer à l'extérieur
de l'hôpital
et encore moins à l'extérieur des
grandes villes donc c'est évidemment un
enjeu tout à fait important rapprocher
la formation des lieux d'installation à
venir
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux la
ministre présentera prochainement des
mesures dans ce sens
autre application de l'ufr des sciences
de la santé qui a convaincu marisol
touraine la mutualisation des moyens
entre différentes disciplines
dans ce laboratoire par exemple les
chercheurs traite des pathologies liées
à des traumatismes de la moelle osseuse
de la recherche fondamentale avec des
buts appliquer au quotidien quand là
la personne a eu un accident de voiture
ou a subi une atteinte au niveau du
système nerveux central
ça a des conséquences sur sa sexualité
et sa comptine ans donc on travaille sur
des modèles animaux de façon à
comprendre et à pallier éventuellement
dans l'avenir c'est trouble particulier
en trouvant des médicaments qui
pourraient agir sur la relaxation delà
de la vessie d'une part ou en
interrogeant plus précisément le système
nerveux central de façon à faire des
thérapies novatrices et en particulier
thérapie à base de transferts de jeunes
l'ufr des sciences de la santé avait été
pensé dès 2003 il est situé à deux pas
du centre commercial régional accueille
mille étudiants en première année et
5000 en totalité les amphis sont plus
adaptées c'est exclusivement des cours
de médecine je pense contrairement à
l'ancienne fac
d'après moi je trouve un peu moins
chaleureuse c'est plus austère ben est
très sympa elle est plus proche de la
gare donc c'est plus rapide donc ces
pratiques
en tout cette ufr compte 125 enseignants
et 18 laboratoires mixtes
[Musique]
on tue et on passe à l'actualité en ile
de france
[Musique]
500 marcheurs 25 moutons 140 km du 6 au
17 juillet la métropole du grand paris
organise la première transhumance
urbaine alors en quoi cela consiste
réponse avec nos confrères de sa grand
paris des moutons qui broutent les bord
du périphérique et de la gare saint
lazare ou encore des vaches qui
déversait parcelles à montreuil des
animaux en pleine ville vous en verrez
encore cet été 25 moutons du troupeau
des bergers urbain accompagné par une
quarantaine de marcheurs traverseront le
territoire francilien
ils passeront par les départements de
seine saint denis du val de marne des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines jusqu'à
paris au total 34 communes seront
visités chaque jour une ville étape 3 en
gros en moyenne trois ou quatre villes
traversées
un cortège d'une trentaine de moutons et
d'à peu près autant de d'accompagnateurs
sous l'égide des berges et urbain qui
eux sont les chefs des moutons et de
cette transhumance à chaque étape de
cette transhumance des événements
culturels et pédagogiques seront
organisées objectif créer des liens
entre les citadins et la nature les
moutons se promèneront dans la rue sur
le trottoir plus exactement dans le
respect du code de la route mais aussi
comme un événement magique qui arrivera
assez urbain
ils rencontreront des moutons tous les
enfants de la métropole n'ont pas le
bonheur de savoir ce qu'est un mouton et
d'en avoir rencontré au bateau au pied
de leur immeuble
cette transhumance urbaine conclu les
rencontres agricole du grand paris
organisé par la métropole la
déambulation des bêtes se fera du 6 au
17 juillet prochain mais je vous propose
de terminer cette émission avec un joli
portrait si pour certains enseignants le
5 juillet marque le début des grandes
vacances et bien pour d'autres il marque
le début d'une nouvelle vie à montigny
le bretonneux et catherine pilot part en
retraite cette année
marylène yapi chenaux et yves hentzen
berger ont suivi ces derniers instants
en classe madame pilot enseignante et
directrice de ce groupe scolaire
alexandre dumas vient flairer la bonne
ambiance de ces olympiades qui sont non
la fin de l'année scolaire
mais si tous se retrouvent à la rentrée
madame pilot elle ne sera plus dans
cette classe qu'elle occupe depuis 28
ans c'est le grand départ celui pour la
retraite
les armoires sont bien rangés prête à à
la passation parce qu'il faut un petit
peu de ton et puis je vous avoue que je
n'ai pas envie de me retrouver au mois
de juillet tout seul dans l'école a
arrangé en 28 ans est celle de classe a
évolué
les murs ont changé de couleur et le
mobilier s'est modernisé les souvenirs
eux restent inscrits c'est qu'un seul
regret j'aurais dû noter toutes les
bêtises tout et les petites et blagues
petites choses qui j'aurais dû les noter
comme ça j'aurai ouvrage aurait dû
ouvrir un cahier puis notez tout ça est
ce qu'il ya un autre métier dans lequel
fois qui apporte autour de joie et
autant de bonheur quoi de si je sais pas
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr que les
enfants ils ont une spontanéité une une
tendresse une confiance qu'on perd
peut-être en grandissant ça j'ai adoré
j'ai adoré car smic
madame pilot enseigne au cm2 une tranche
d'âge qu'elle a toujours conservé
elle est aussi la directrice tout est
prêt pour ma remplaçante ouvre en fait
même étiqueté tout pour que ce soit plus
un courage j'appréhende un petit peu
parce que je me lance qui commence à
être à retraite mais je suis prête à
partir
un nouveau départ en dessous des bons
souvenirs
alors pour une directrice qui aura
autant marqué l'histoire de son école
impossible de passer à côté du pot de
départ un groupe de parents d'élèves ces
mêmes constitués en comité
d'organisation pour que la fête soit
réussie
près de 300 personnes se sont réunies et
on a il y en a qui sont venus du
périgord yanek est venue de roumanie il
a pris l'avion pour revenir de roumanie
ce que je vous dis c'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de
bonheur ouais c'est plein d'émotions
plein de souvenirs qui reviennent et
danser une directrice en or il n'y a pas
d'autre moi c'est vraiment exceptionnel
des discours de nombreux cadeaux et une
chanson pour dire au revoir et chapeau à
cette pétillante madame pilot merci et
bonne retraite à l bonne retraite à tous
les enseignants et puis bien sûr très
bonnes vacances à tous les concernés
voilà c'est la fin de ce cette fuite
l'hebdo merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité en direct ce sera
lundi à 18 heures et puis bien sûr 24
heures sur 24 vous pouvez toujours
retrouver toute l'actualité sur notre
site internet www.tv5monde.com très bon
week-end à tous
[Musique]